le personnel non médical en grève depuis
trois semaines s'est réunie devant
l'hôpital bretonneau en début d'après
midi étaient également présents le
service de stérilisation de bretonneau
en grève depuis mercredi dernier le
personnel non médical des urgences
réclament toujours des créations de
postes que ce soit des infirmières ou
des brancardiers on écoute l'un des
grévistes philippe hervé il est
infirmier de nuit à trousseau nous
sommes en grève actuellement pour
réclamer des postes la direction
générale pour l'instant n'a pas répondu
à nos attentes donc nous continuons la
grève les postes qui nous ont proposés
sont largement insuffisantes pour
pouvoir boucher combler les trous qu'il
existe dans notre service les trous
existe depuis l'ouverture des nouvelles
urgences à trousseau depuis donc 2003 et
les problèmes s'aggravent le nombre de
passagers est largement supérieur aux
possibilités de soins nous ne sommes pas
assez de soignants et les gens sont
parfois
abandonné entre guillemets un petit peu
parce que ben on peut pas être partout